do you know what it feels like to be 26
years old have people that you went to
high school with come to your liquor
store look you dead in the face as they
pulled up in their BMW and say oh you
work for your dad and then you ring them
up on their case of champagne and you
bring it out to their car and put it in
their trunk and they look you in the
face with pity I lived that life and the
way I took that scene was I'll see you
in ten years [ __ ]
[Music]
you know it's funnier I was driving here
this morning it's like what I want to
what do I want to get off what I want to
make sure they know the number one thing
if I leave this morning that I hope is
for people to realize how much leverage
they have how you just like weight room
and film you've got to put in work to
get what you want and how what social
media on the internet have done is given
you so much opportunity to take
advantage of who you engage with around
what you want I think the biggest
vulnerability to this room including the
coaches and us old guys is patience
I wish the coaches over here knew how
young they were watching 30 40 50 year
olds completely confused by the context
of time is one of the most fascinating
things I see in our society like people
always come up to me and I Gary when you
gonna buy the Jets and I'm like 25 years
and they get sad as [ __ ] like they think
they like want me to have it tomorrow it
was a really famous basketball college
team Loyola Marymount every time I think
about that team its how I think about my
life and how I think about myself as an
entrepreneur they were when college
basketball games like 147 to 132 they
were just running shoes they were just
they just pushed it their games were
crazy and that's how I think about life
I think too many people are playing
defense and I'm out here trying to win
149 to 146 offense because once you stop
hearing judgment and you're not actually
worried about what people have to say
you can just go fast judgment is the
only thing I promise you that you'll
have for the rest of your life
[Music]
choose from afar I'm like that's really
good parenting really good DNA and
really good circumstance cuz that kid is
not in support we have instant well
that's right
truly truly one of my favorite people
give some love to Caleb
[Music]
Oh Gary I'm from motional it's so funny
that the only thing just happened kind
of organic yeah this is more gray in my
opinion do you believe in aliens
straight up
yes I'm gonna really miss you are you
trying to do a Peppa so tabasco be
together everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 320 of
the askgaryvee show and this is a very
exciting episode because the person that
will be dialling the questions and
getting to the questions today is India
our very own India who's on her last day
after seven years at vaynermedia fun
fact for a lot of you that don't know
India was a superstar but you know you
know how sometimes they like you know
how like Ari Gold actually became the
star of Entourage but that wasn't the
purpose there was absolutely a time in
2016 in 2016 where India was the my main
co-host of the show when it was a
completely call-in show or or take
questions from the internet show and you
know the reason I had to get her off the
show was it became clear to me that she
had to become bigger than me and I
wasn't really willing to deal with that
you know when you're like 54 another fun
things to say I believe you
pull it off no really I did this yeah
people don't even know this thing I've
had a couple again informational
interviews and they're like oh what
you've been doing for me
here in like so much including like this
like show I did would like to see yo
Gary and they're like I don't like yeah
that's true like we just did it you know
like really did yeah
so that's been awesome to just to have
that experience to talk about and like
everyone loves you when I bring you up
you know so like that's just great for
me like I know that's that's what I
really wanted to lean it like I am ready
to like get a phone call in the middle
of a meeting and it's your phone number
yeah and I'm assuming you keep me at
that moment before like whatever
interview or whatever you're in that I'm
gonna pick it up and be like no Rick but
you should hire her yeah puck Rick he's
always the one you go for Rick and
salarik Insalaco
yeah I really appreciate that hey
Cynthia this is Gary Vaynerchuk hi I was
just walking by I'm actually running out
of the building but I saw Andrew on the
phone I said whoever you're talking to I
want to say hello and then he said she
flipped $4000 stuff and then I said I
really want to say hello hello I really
really have to run I'm super late but I
want to say hi thank you for watching my
content
[Music]
it's [ __ ] pouring
that's awesome
all right do we have an umbrella we do
foxy rock let's go
[Music]
I'm here I'm in my home
the Jets facility what up Jets
yo Sam Darnell Jamal if you're watching
come through I'm judging this Shark Tank
Lake business challenge I'm [ __ ] home
New York Jets baby [ __ ] home thank
you very much we'll actually let's do
even better what's their names Robert
Anthony listen I'm here with pops I have
no idea why the [ __ ] you guys aren't
here but we're hustling we're best
friends now and I can't wait to meet you
guys yeah real pleasure nice to see you
look this is America small businesses
and Main Street businesses and
entrepreneurs drive this economy it's
black and white data without these small
businesses the whole machine of this
great country doesn't play out and so
coming from a small business environment
being an investor in small businesses
being an entrepreneur I mean this is
home for me for my 15 behind 22 behind
Oh Ted
was I yesterday like wait a minute this
wasn't the one where I promised you I
was done at 3:00 p.m. Jason
yep not you know I've caught
I usually am it's really devastating for
everybody around me